foreign
[Music]
Excel Technologies application and
resource center and today what I'm gonna
talk about is actually a related with
crispr Gene editing especially for the
nuclease editing with base editor or the
prime editor site when we look at the
how crispr Gene editing toolbox
improving especially in 2017 and 2019
there are two different nucleus and the
turtle Technologies combined with a
crispr cast system one is the base
editor especially in that cases the
nucleus cas9
enzyme is joined with the cytosine
deaminase or the adenosine the aminase
to change the cytosine or the adenine to
the timing or the guanine
on the other side in 2019 what we have
seen that especially Prime editor system
is improved with the nuclear the Nikki
is cas9 enzyme at that case is joined
with the reverse transcriptase at that
case especially we instead of changing
these single nucleotides
we could change or insert any deleted
nucleotide or combination of them when
we have a look at the detail of this
true technology we see that cytosine
diamines and Adonis in the anonymous
systems are working together and we see
that for the cytosine the aminase
decrease system especially use the
Nikkei system and with the help of
niches cas9 instead of producing the
double strand break on the DNA because
it can produce the off-target mutations
at that case that just produced a nick
nick breakage on the single strand of
the DNA and with the help of this
cytosine diaminase the cytosine can be
converted into the urine and in the
later cases especially in DNA
replication this urine will be the
timing on the other hand when we look at
the adoles in the aminase in that case
especially the DNA replication have to
innocent to change into the Guan and
what they have help of these two base
editor system
especially for the single nucleotide
polymorphisms a single-neutilated
mutations causing the rare diseases can
be affixed with the help of this single
base editor systems and when we look at
the detail especially there are kind of
the complications and one complication
is that not only the targeted nucleotide
but also the bystander nicotas can be
also converted and as you can see here
that for the cytos and the aminase you
can see that the adenine can be
converted yes but however the bystander
adenine can be also converted into the
guanet and the same cases is also true
for the uh cytosine de aminase and you
can see that the target cytosine can be
converted to the timing however the
bystander time cytosine can be also
converted to timing and that kind of the
limitations are still getting trouble in
the base editor system however
especially for the targeted in
nucleotide
with the help of without any and DNA
double strand break especially this
helps to fix the any mutations so how we
can design the guide RNA for the crispr
cast base editor system especially
badgelink.com is the free user
platform you can you can enter the any
DNA or a raw DNA sequences into that
system or you can find the gene of the
interest from the system and this system
help us to find what kind
editor guide rnas can be useful for you
for example for here I entered one of
the example I entered the dushan
dysrophy gene DMD Gene and I selected
the genome as a homo sapiens genome and
then for the Pam sequences which is the
protospacer adjacent motive which is
important for the recognition of cast 9
and for the cast iron time sequences the
I selected ngg sequences and after that
cases what we have seen that if we
wanted to change or repair any mutation
single negative mutations on the axon
side so you can select the Exon exonic
sequences and the system automatically
detect all the base editor potential
guides earnings on the right side you
can see that the red boxes at that red
boxes uh or the Neve and amino acids
after the base editor system can change
the nucleotide which might be either
cytosine the aminate or the adenos and
the harmonies and this is up to you
especially if you wanted to change to
any variance or the mutation takes place
in a genome this card this could be the
old Vision how you can change the
nucleotides to Neve amino acid this is
not only the human cells but also the
plant and other animal cells are could
be the useful applications because if
you wanted to produce the targeted
motogenesis this kind of Technology
might be useful to increase the
mutations or the capacity of the
physiology or function of the protein
and you can see here that not only one
uh your type change but also you can
combine these cytosine de-aminase and
the Adolescent diameters at the same
time only one base editor system at that
case what happened not only changed the
cytos into timing you can at the same
time change the other other into the
guanine and this kind of
combinations can increase your
mutagenesis or you can increase your
repairing capacity on the other hand
with the help of this cytosine the
harmonize system you can even delete a
certain strand of the DNA from just
single strap because the base editor
system produced The Niche breakage and
on the other hand what I'm gonna come
with is the prime editing system and at
that cases this all the game is changing
and what you can see here that with this
cytosine diaminase and adenosine the
harmonates the critical point is the DNA
replication because what the help of
this base editor system you can either
change the cytosine to urine or the
adenosine to inosin and this in in Ozone
and urine is not a usual in the DNA
sequences or or for the Chino and what
we have should see that the DNA
replication of the cell and after the
replication takes place in the cell then
this uridine can convert it into the
timing or this innocent can be converted
into the guanine and that's a cycle
should be the completed with this
replication of the cell and that time
you can either change the cytosine to a
timing or the coordinate adding into the
guanine or or you can combine these two
enzyme capability in our single base
editor enzyme if we wanted to change
both of them at the same time and the
the next question will come that not
only to change the single nucleotide
polymorphism to edit an immutage
analysis what about the insert the
sequences or delete single sequences
from that that it targets and this kind
of
applications were not applicable for
base editor that's why in 2019
especially Prime editing system is
developed and with the help of this
system you can do anything similar to
the base editor system and you can even
improve the insertion and deletion of
the sequences with the reverse
transcriptase domain and you can see
here that the these DNA changes are not
limited for the genome and instead of
using nikkei's case 9 you can change
this cas9 system because cas9 can bind
to the DNA sequences you can change case
nine to to PES 13 and this case 13 as we
know that that can bind to the RNA and
you know by convey and combining the
cash 13 with the cytosine the harmonase
or Adonis in the arminase you can change
this nucleotides on the RNA sequences
and this can increase the Exon inclusion
or the other uh
variable
splicing actions and that's why not only
the DNA repairing but also RNA
modifications can be applicable with the
help of Base editor systems and
on the other hand using the prime editor
system you are now limited to DNA
however with the new improvements uh
this Kester team might be joined with
the reverse transcriptase at that time
you can you can you cannot you cannot
change the DNA sequences however it
might have to increase the RNA
efficiency based on the results and what
we have come for uh for the base editors
especially these systems getting
improving because there are many
different limitations so when we look at
the crispr cast system especially not
only the nucleus limitations but also
delivery detection and preparations are
the other limitations however when we
focus on the base editor disadvantages
there are kind of the obstacles one of
the obstacle is that the base editing
product a purity Purity means that
because there are the bystander editing
and the other unwanted
nucleotide modifications the purity of
this targeted nucleotide change is not
stable or not improved yet however on
the other hand the generation of
insertion deletion mutations or of
target editing are still getting
improved because this nicked knee case a
cas9 systems although it only produced a
Nick breakage on the single strand DNA
still there's some possibility to
produce the off target editing and
that's why when we look at the
limitations of the base editor system
there are still some way through going
on
and next side let's look at the base
address system to compare with the HDR
system
although there are some limitations on
base editor when we compare with
homology directory repair system
especially base editor has still some
Advantage one of the advantages is that
when when you need to change any
nucleotide on the DNA with the type of
HDR system you need to also add the
donor DNA into the cell however for the
base editor system you you do not need
to have any more the DNA sequences as a
reference sequence that's why with the
only base editor system the single guide
RNA and the base editor
nucleuses are enough to edit any
targeted sequences and that's why still
base editor system has a great advantage
and great a mutation or modification
capacity rather than the classic cas9
HDR systems
let's look at the prime editor system
and at that cases uh what we are going
to use instead of cytosine diaminase and
adenos in the arminase now we combine
reverse transcriptase within any case
kes9 and at that cases all guide RNA
sequences are also getting change and in
that case uh while we are producing the
20 to 25
spacer sequences this space asyncosons
will be joined with the guide RNA
scaffold as the conventional sequences
and that and that cases this sequence
are also joined with two other sequences
one is primer binding site the other one
is the rtt reverse transcriptase
template and these two sequences are
also in this RNA form and that produce
the guard RNA as Prime editing card RNA
and namely PEC RNA and that PEC RNA will
help a reverse transcriptase to change
to convert the PBS and rtt sequences
into the DNA platform and then the
recombination takes place between these
uh converted DNA sequences into the into
the Chino and why this system is getting
very popular because
with respect to homology directory
repair in that cases we were using the
donor DNA to change the targeted
sequences
here we do not need any donor DNA
because we insert the donor DNA
sequences into the PEC RNA sequences as
a primer binding site and reverse
transcriptase template and when you
design this PBS and rtt sequences in the
PEC RNA you are enough to you are enough
to start your
Gene modification
and you can see here that similar to
base editor the Nikkei system produced a
single and a Nick and nickaj on the
single strand of DNA and the other
strand can be can be combined or can be
recombined with the with the PBS and rtt
sequences and the Studies have shown
that up to 89 of all the uh variants all
the mutations uh detected in the human
genome can be fixed with the help of
prime editor
system and you can see here that not
only the transition mutations but also
transversion mutations can be fixed with
the help of prime editing and not only
like the base editor but also the
primary editor system could insert or
delete any targeted sequences up to 40
base pair and you can combine each of
these modifications on your pack RNA
sequences in the PBS and rtt site and
with the help of that system not only
change the single nucleotide
polymorphism you can even insert any or
the delete any targeted sequences in a
single pack RNA that's why this system
getting improved and getting a popular
especially for the rare diseases we know
that there is 75
000 of different pathological mutations
taking place in human genome and this
calls the 7000 rare diseases and 89 of
this genetic abnormalities can be fixed
based on the prime editing system
because Transitions and transversion of
the nucleotides are are able to be fixed
with this system and also 40 best pair
of the deletions or insertions can be
takes place with the half of this Prime
editor system so how we can design the
PEC RNA especially there are kind of
different uh websites or databases one
of them is the prime edit Dot
nygenome.org and in that cases you have
two potential capacity one is the you
can produce the pack RNA to Pro to make
the disease models in the animals on the
other hand if you wanted to focus to
repair any mutations in the human genome
then you can produce or you can select a
PEC RNA on that databases with the help
of therapeutic Gene editing and in both
cases the database produced The Pack RNA
with the help of spacers spacer sequence
to the specific side of the variation
and then PBS and rtt sequences at the
same time to change to your targeted
variations and how you can go on that
website you can see that after enter the
the website you can see Prime editing
designer and you can select this click
and then you will show that
the gene sample or the clinical variant
ID and especially for clinical variant
databases you can find any any mutations
causing their in the genetic abnormality
and after you select the numbers of
these
clinical variants you can add the gene
symbol or the economic covariant ID into
the system and then you can change
your aim either therapeutic or modeling
and if you wanted to repair the
mutations you can select therapeutic
action and then you can change the off
targets score especially Prime editing
system is similar to base editor system
has the or almost 300 times less less of
Target mutation uh capacity rather than
the conventional cas9 system that's why
these systems are getting popular to be
entered into clinical stages and in that
example I selected the MD Gene and when
I entered to the DMD Gene the the
database has produced more than
700 to 700 different pack rnas specific
to different pathological variance
previously determined and the all-pack
RNA is previously designed to be studied
and you can see here that there are kind
of different details therefore the each
pack or unpack rnas and you can see that
the the reference nucleotides was timing
however you can change this timing from
the cytosine and this effect RNA
database produced the strna sequences
and then PBS and rtt sequences with the
help of the the conversion of cytosine
to the timing and that's why you can
either select the the right side of this
website this is a very very big website
especially It produced all the data for
for your PEC RNA before you're starting
experiments and you can see here that
the efficiency The Binding capability
and the off Target mutations can be also
determined based on the the algorithm uh
in the in the databases and uh we used
especially this system we say we
designed several guide or impact rnas on
that system in my laboratory especially
we started in the first time that we
focus on spinar muscular atrophy and in
the SMA disease especially there are two
different Gene one is the survival motor
neuron Gene one the other one is SM
antugene and what we have done that by
changing SM ant-2 gene into the smn1
gene with the help of PEC RNA system to
do that especially we designed couple of
pack rnas and and caught this in the
land wire system and then we transduced
the cells and to change the single
nucleotide polymorphism to mimic the
smm-1 gene because in the SMA patients
especially
sml1gen is mutated and the loss of
functions takes place and only the smm
protein produced by the SM antugene
however the production is not enough and
by doing the prime editing system in the
first time uh for the SMA disease we can
we could show that this smn2 Gene change
into the sml1 Gene and permanently
started to produce SMN protein and you
can see here that is the flow of
cytometry charts and you can see that
the gfp encoding cells which is which is
the biomarker for the prime editor
system especially you can find this kind
of prime editing and base is editing a
plasma dnas in the edging databases and
this is also got from the edging website
and then we cloned the pack RNs into
that vectors and after transduction of
the cells we follow up up to a 14 to 21
days and we could show that the smm
protein after the changing single
nucleotide sequences in the smn2 gene we
could increase the protein expression
from a 1.7 percent up to the 91 percent
and that's why the prime editing system
now getting very in very interesting
because this system is also permanent
Gene modifications and with the with the
help of
improved and the less of Target capacity
and if we don't any unwanted and
modifications this is the future for the
clinical trials and you can see here
that the Gina called and the the gene
replacement with the homology direct
repair are getting a change into the two
different Gene repair system one is the
base editing the other one is the prime
editing system both systems are
applicable for the genetic modifications
especially for single nucleotide
polymorphisms not only for the human
disease but also plant and animal
mutagen as the studies are getting
important because you can see here that
when we look at the plant traits or the
crop trades you can use the base Edition
systems to to to make the nucleotide
exchange and with the help of this
system you can improve the herbicide
resistance
on the other hand you can also produce
the target Automotive Genesis in the
modified hormone genes in the tomato or
the chromosome eliminations in the Maze
and that's why with the help of Maize
and base editing and the prime editing
systems you can you can do any of the
targeted emotic Genesis uh not only in
the patients but also in the plants and
when we look at the the system how we
can develop the better platforms on the
base editor or the prime editor system
you can change the uh the cas9 sequences
or you can code on optimize the cas9
sequences instead of using cast iron you
can use the cpf1 or the other cas9
autolux on the other hand we can combine
these cytosine diaminase or adenosine de
Amino with the other diamness
systems and the you can also change the
reverse transcriptase on the prime
editor enzyme from different viruses
different wires genome and the delivery
is very important not only for base
editor but also for the prime editor
systems and Prime editing system
especially has a very long TNA sequences
that's why for example other Associated
wires is not enough to carry any Prime
editing system maybe do and dual I don't
know Associated wires Delivery Systems
could be useful for Prime editing
however for base editor system which is
much useful however cas9 sequences are
still very long instead of using test9
maybe you can change this base edit
through systems or nucleus editing
systems with a cpf1 likes and proteins
and because they have their very short
and harmonize sequences on the other
hand we also need to improve the
analysis because after using the base
editing or nucleus editing system the
genotyping or phenotyping of the cells
or tissue are very important and we need
to also determine any unwanted editing
after these two new test editing system
so after we come up with all Improvement
and optimization we are going to be
ready for clinical qualification of Base
editor or prime editor systems for the
7000 different rare diseases and thank
you very much for listening to me I hope
these two kind of the toolbox are be
useful for your studies